so halloween happened over the weekend
and i know halloween i believe was
technically cancelled this year
because uh you're not allowed to go
outside or see people and we're supposed
to look at everyone like a big bag of
germs and by the way joe biden says
we're gonna have masks through what 2022
or something like that that's what fauci
is saying now too so
if you like that kind of a situation you
want to vote for more of it
vote for biden if you want to vote for
reopening the country vote for trump
some people still wore halloween
costumes alyssa milano went out there
and dressed as this is my this is the
favorite costume this year for the left
r b g the late justice ruth ginsburg
so first she tweets out uh happy
halloween
rgb forever rgb
rgb is it rgb ruth ginsburg bader no
that's not her name
you love this woman so much but you
don't you don't know her name
okay then she deletes that tweet and
repost says happy halloween
ruth bader ginsburg notorious rbg
but then i looked at how did she spell
ginsburg g-i-n-s-b-e-r-g
not how you spell ginsburg
so the left we are told we have to take
them seriously
on matters of jurisprudence on matters
of political philosophy
matters of the constitution even the
justices that they love
that they idolize truly idolize they
can't
spell their names dude maybe the third
time was the charm i don't know if she
tried a third go
they don't know anything about this i
mean you saw it especially
last week when they redefined court
packing
court packing has a specific definition
so when you add
justices to the supreme court you
increase the number of justices
so that you are more likely to get a
judicial ruling favorable to you
they redefined that absolutely
definite possibility
with adding justices to replace justices
who had left
meaning following the constitution
reappointing justices to the court they
conflated those two things
very dishonestly but the mainstream
media totally went with them
all of a sudden the minute you had one
or two people mention this in the air
everybody new york times the cable news
channels came in and they said well
republicans have been court backing too
they haven't they haven't they've just
been appointing judges as the
constitution tells them to do
completely different situation
republicans and conservatives have no
responsibility
to engage in these bad faith debates
with them they're not having a debate
they don't know anything about this and
they don't want to know anything about
this they don't want to know anything
about the constitution they don't want
to know anything about the law
they don't want to know anything about
our founding they don't like our
founding
they don't like the country the premise
of progressivism now going back 100
years
is that the founding of the country was
wrong and mistaken
and now we need something else we need
to change it fundamentally
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode
linked in the description or download
the podcast wherever you listen to
[Music]
podcasts
[Music]
you